[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
i
my
[Music]
so
hey everyone good evening and welcome to
the table
it is sunday night and we are live
i hope all of you had a safe and
wonderful thanksgiving
uh whatever shape or form it took
in this pandemic season um i want to
welcome you here especially if you are
new watching us for the first time
uh i hope that uh this service tonight
feels connecting for you
that um
it helps you to remember that you are
not alone and that you are welcome here
um
i just have one announcement for tonight
and uh it's you know christmas it's kind
of a big deal for christians
um
you know
gosh this pandemic is no respecter
of
holy holidays
as we saw during easter
several months ago and it's the same for
christmas
our hearts desire is to do an outdoor
service the afternoon of christmas eve
at pleasant valley
to have everybody gather
at a safe distance and and do all that
but we just don't know right now the
numbers are going in the wrong direction
in this area
so
as always we are going to be guided by
our values
and by the numbers and we will continue
to err on the side of wisdom and safety
for everyone
so
we may do an outdoor service we may not
but we will keep you posted as
as it gets closer
um
and speaking of brett just sent out an
email update with some information on a
possible christmas service as well as
some other information about the table
and the state of the table so if you did
not get that email and you want to get
that email please just comment down
below and
just say email
updates and we'll make sure to get you
those emails as as we send them out that
will keep you most up-to-date on what's
going on at the table
and speaking of christmas um
i would love to know what your favorite
christmas song or christmas carol is so
uh take a moment right now and comment
what's yours mine is a holy night like
that is seriously my favorite um it's
always been my favorite and
as i was thinking about that song today
gosh that line that says
a thrill of hope
a weary
world rejoices
could not be more appropriate
during this year so wherever you are
and however we end up celebrating
christmas at the table we'll do it in a
connecting way whether it's online or in
person
uh but you will have a seat at the table
for christmas this year so i hope you
will join us
all right as we transition into worship
uh which is such a treat i can't wait
for you to to see this
worship collaboration with some of my
favorites um let's take a moment to
center on god
take a deep breath
i'm not sure how your week has been but
mine has been all over the place
and i could use some centering and just
a reminder that no matter what you're
going through
god is always with you
and he sees you and he loves you
so close your eyes and
let's pray together
god
we center on you tonight we remember
that you are always with us
that
you love us
that you are good
and that we can trust you
god thank you for being an anchor
and for being a refuge
so we give you every worried thought we
give you every fear we give you every
thing that is praiseworthy everything
that brings us to our knees
in tears and
god we give it all to you knowing that
you are always there for us
and that you are the source of hope
and peace
so right now i speak peace over each
person
tuning in right now
your peace god that passes understanding
that passes circumstances
that surpasses everything we're going
through right now and reminds us that
there is a hope and a future in you so
god i pray that you would remind each
one of us of that tonight
through the songs
through words that are spoken through
the message and the sharing
the prayers god may each each word each
song lyric each note be a reminder of
your love your goodness and your
nearness
in jesus name
amen
hey guys we are so excited to be
worshiping together tonight for one of
the very few times since all of this
crazy pandemic began and i hope that
this time
for you is a blessing i hope that you're
able to
relax and feel at home
because um
that is who god is for us he our home he
is our beginning he is our starting
point
um so i hope that that's where you find
yourself tonight as well
you guys just engage with us um as
you're able to
we've been hiding
in the shadows
[Music]
we
we are
[Music]
oh
you've been waiting
to show us mercy
your presidencies
[Music]
we are
we are known to
to the bridge
[Music]
is
there is no
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
there is no feeling
anymore
[Music]
is
know
[Music]
foreign
you make all things
[Music]
we're together
for your glory
[Music]
oh
is my future
[Music]
is
you make
[Music]
you're not
foreign
[Music]
with me
i have decided
to follow jesus
no turning
[Applause]
[Music]
world back
me
the cross before
the world behind me
me
[Music]
no turning back
[Applause]
[Music]
still i will follow
no turning back
[Music]
god thank you that you
are a part of our journeys you're a part
of our stories and it's not about
getting it right
it's not even just about the end but
it's about what we're learning along the
way
thank you for loving us right where
we're at each step of the journey
when we stumble you're with us
when we fall you love us
you are our home
and you are the one that we want to
return to god
be with us today
guide us tomorrow god
and make us more like you
hey everyone
well good evening
grace and peace
welcome to the table
uh my name is brett and the pastor here
uh and it's just it's really great to be
with you really really great so uh we
are in
uh week two in our series titled stretch
thin
what to do when life pushes you to the
limit and this has been
uh you know just a season where many of
us have have felt stretched too thin uh
in the wise words of bilbo baggins
and right here i've already lost
everyone under the age of 30.
maybe mid-20s maybe some of you upper
20s no bilbo baggins maybe uh but he
said this he said i feel thin sort of
stretched like butter scraped over too
much bread
and i love that imagery and i'd say um
that about sums up our year so far you
know if our life energy is the butter
this year has been too much sourdough
and the butter has run out and yet that
that knife just keeps on scraping
and so uh so what we want to do in this
series is just to look again to the god
we've come to know in jesus uh for some
resources for some wisdom for some
insight uh to help us thrive in this
season um and in the first
few weeks of this this series um we'll
be in many kind of different passages
all over the bible as we go a little bit
farther into it um we'll kind of start
to intersect with advent and some of the
stories around the birth of christ and
things um so so last week just to recap
last week if you you weren't here we
kicked off the series and we discussed
our brains uh negativity bias and how we
need to begin living in a sense of
awareness awareness of ourselves uh
awareness of the world around us of god
to to start to kind of increase our
faith and our sense of connection to god
um and so the way we kind of summed it
up uh last week was with the phrase to
worry is human to find peace
divine uh so that was last week if you
missed it you can find that
on our podcast
next week we'll be looking at the
mysterious power um of of our words of
speech uh in the way they um just direct
our lives in so many ways um so that'll
be next week
but for tonight uh the title of my
message is all alone
and i don't think it will come as some
sort of huge shock to hear that uh we
are living through um not just a
pandemic but really an epidemic of
loneliness
uh in the united states uh this was true
even prior to the the covid um 19
pandemic uh but if we had you know any
doubt then i suspect uh the last nine
months have pretty much put that to to
rest um and i know
just from the the occasional coffee
connections i'm having with some of you
to the the many text conversations and
the occasional phone calls um
i i know you know that loneliness
that sense of of isolation that has been
a real struggle uh for many folks in our
community uh and so the way i want to
kind of define loneliness tonight um
it's you know it's one of those things
that like i mean we all know but but um
sometimes maybe we lack words so let me
give you a little a few words for
tonight loneliness is is that it's a gap
between the sense of connectedness
that i have
and what i need
a gap between the sense of connectedness
i have and what i need uh i listen to a
podcast conversation between vivec murty
and brene brown on this topic a huge
thank you to karen miner she sent it my
way uh and and i found it really
insightful um but one of the things they
named
is that you know offering a definition
of loneliness doesn't quite get at the
feeling
the the experience
of loneliness and in that in fact for
that uh really only metaphors and word
pictures will do uh so i want to share a
few with you um i recall an article
i read this was man probably years ago
about the experience
of homelessness
uh and uh and this kind of came from
someone who lived outside for a long
period of time
and later they they reflected on the
experience and what they named they said
the hardest part
was that as uh
as a homeless person
they they sort of
faded into the background of the city
almost like you know how when you're
walking through a city there's a lot of
objects and there's a lot of things you
have like concrete sidewalk here parking
meter there
and then someone who lives outside you
know over there
uh but but they're all
they're all just kind of objects just
part of the city you know
landscape so to speak and this this
person they said um
once i once i took on
the the look
the the vibe the smell you know of
homelessness
i effectively became
invisible
that was their word
i became invisible
is that
loneliness invisibility
when we are lonely we feel
so invisible
there's a beautiful passage in galatians
chapter 6
verse
um
where the apostle paul
um he's writing a letter to a small
church um just like ours and actually
sorry it's verse 14 galatians 6 14 he
says this bear one another's burdens
and so fulfill the law
of christ isn't that wonderful to have a
sense of of connectedness a sense of
community a sense that there are people
who will help me help you bear the
emotional burdens of life
to have people there that i can turn to
when things get just too
heavy people i can open up and share
with and through my words i can as this
first kind of names i can um transfer
a little of my burden to them
and then they in love
and loves the word right that's the law
of christ that's what it means they love
love they in love they then they absorb
a little of that burden into their very
bodies
bear one another's burdens and so
fulfill the law of christ
and i feel in that moment
have you ever experienced that you you
know what it is to to kind of feel
emotionally
unburdened
isn't that wonderful what a grace
but of course the reverse is also true
what pain
to have
a heavy
emotional burden and yet have no one to
turn to
that's another picture of loneliness
it's like it's like having a burden
that i must carry
alone
and yet we we might say
that what is strange
about the tree of loneliness is that
while its roots go deep in us
its visible leaves which we might call
it symptoms can often manifest in in
just a variety of different ways
such that this is what's so strange we
can be lonely
and not even realize
we are lonely
because because we're we're looking at
the leaves so to speak we're looking at
the symptoms
and not the roots for example
when we lash out in anger
it can actually be loneliness that's
driving us towards that when we uh when
we withdraw from others
it can actually be rooted quite
strangely enough in loneliness like
you'd think no we would never isolate
when we're lonely um
that's not all the case we
uh we we often kind of pull away not
realizing
why we're pulling away but it's because
we're lonely when um when we turn to
substances that numb food that comforts
um one night stands
uh that others you know may look at and
just think like that's just nothing more
than you know worldly sexual lust or
something and yet they just might be
desperate attempts to stave off the
choking loneliness um that we feel
uh in that interview or uh where brene
brown was interviewing um vivek murti
she um told a story
i think she heard this from another
psychiatrist uh where they were in
charge of um overseeing the mental
health of um troops in the us military
and
um so they were interviewing or they
were um kind of meeting with various um
soldiers and and she was you know um
asking like you know how are you doing
and what they kept saying was um i'm
tired
i'm tired how are you i'm tired i'm
tired just kept this word i'm tired i'm
tired and she she couldn't quite figure
out like what what's underneath this or
what's what's going on here i mean
they're getting the sleep they need
um but as she began to ask questions and
go a little deeper
she realized
uh they're lonely
they're lonely
uh right because all of a sudden their
life had changed like they're living on
on either on a base or maybe even
deployed and away from family and they
were lonely but they were but it was
manifesting as fatigue as they're saying
i'm tired i'm tired i'm tired but but
that's what happens right with the tree
of loneliness its roots um it can
actually be it can kind of um be quite
different right we don't realize it's
loneliness um that we're experiencing
uh in other words you might say
you know loneliness isn't necessarily
the the somewhat stereotypical
thing we imagine
for example if you imagine a lonely
person uh you know you might envision
someone maybe at the party you know
sitting in the corner hoodie pulled over
their foreheads
talking to no one and you look at them
you say oh they're so lovely uh but of
course
it's rare
for
social isolation to be that obvious
um in fact this is what's fascinating a
study by cigna insurance from january of
this year found uh that more than three
in five americans that's 60 of the
population reported feeling here's the
list lonely
left out
poorly understood in lacking
companionship
and i mentioned the date on this study
because it's important to note that was
before
the pandemic
not remarkable 60 of people us uh adults
before
we for the sake of saving lives began to
intentionally
distance ourselves uh and so i mean 60
that is to say think about the majority
of people you and i interact with each
day
um the majority even possibly of folks
um listening to me right now
are
lonely
it's it's an epidemic it's a huge huge
problem
which is why it seems not insignificant
that so much of the bible concerns
itself with what
with relationship
with with connection
with the brokenness of humanity with the
ways that we become invisible to one
another with the ways that we can fail
to bear one another's burdens that we
can
fail to see one another fail to love one
another but then in jesus christ god
among us god with us god slips into skin
and like the great artist he is what
does he do he begins to restore the
image of god in each of us and and we
find our sense of identity and value in
him and what happens we are then
empowered to connect with others at
whole new levels
which is why there are so many
statements
in the new testament um known as the one
anothers if you if you grew up in church
uh these are probably familiar to you uh
but if you didn't
that's perfectly okay because honestly
you're not you're not far behind these
are like these are statements you can
learn in a moment
this is like super super simple stuff
at least on a surface
and you
just try to live them and
find uh they are anything
but easy they're really kind of anything
but ordinary in our culture
um
and and in many ways i think they are
the way
that um the spirit of god empowers us as
the church to begin to break the chains
of loneliness
in our own lives
and in our communities
here's this is just a sample of them
from the new testament
love
one another
be devoted
to one another
honor one another above
yourselves live in harmony
with one another build up
one another be like-minded towards one
another accept
one another admonish
one another greet one another care for
one another serve one another bear one
another's burdens forgive
one another be patient with one another
speak the truth in
love
be kind and compassionate to one another
speak to one another with psalms and
hymns and spiritual songs submit to one
another consider others better than
yourselves look to the interests of one
another bear with one another teach one
another
comfort one another encourage one
another exhort one another stir up one
another to love in good works show
hospitality to one another employ the
gifts that god has given us for the
benefit of one another clothe yourselves
with humility towards one another pray
for one another confess your faults to
one another
ah that's a long list i'm i'm really
glad i've been running because i might
have lost my wind
that's um those are beautiful i love
that last one uh that confess your
faults to one another um because in many
ways that brings us right to the
doorstep of a wonderful insight from a
theologian um and christian martyr
diedrich bonhoeffer that i found a few
weeks back he writes this
he says it may be
that christians right so he's talking
about the church here um notwithstanding
which means kind of in spite of all of
our corporate worship
common prayer
all of their fellowship and service you
know as we serve one another um we may
still be left
or that they may still be left to their
loneliness bonhoeffer says the final
breakthrough to fellowship
does not occur
because
though they have fellowship with one
another as believers and devout people
they do not have fellowship as the
undevout
as
sinners
the pious fellowship
he continues permits no one to be a
sinner so everyone must conceal his sin
from himself
from the fellowship in that interesting
from himself or or herself and from the
broader community so
we remain alone
with our sin
living in lies
in hypocrisy
it's a heavy quote but i think what it
names so powerfully
is uh is that it's not enough to simply
be around other people all right this is
kind of the the simple mistake that we
often make when we're lonely we think to
ourselves i just
i just need to be around some people
just get just get me around some people
uh and there's of course a grain of
truth in that i mean we do need of
course fellowship connection with others
um tough to break out of loneliness if
you're totally isolated
so there's truth in that but here's the
key and this is what i think we get from
bonhoeffer's line um and from that final
one another um
that if
we are not there in that community in
that
in that moment of connection if we are
not there as our true selves
if we are trying to pretend to be
someone different
than we actually are
if we feel the need to perform
to earn
love and approval if we are not honest
and vulnerable
then frankly we can be around people all
day long
and yet
still
feel
lonely
in other words
where there is no vulnerability
there is no true community
where there is no vulnerability there is
no true community but of course the
beautiful thing
is that when we move in the opposite
spirit of that what happens when we are
brave and vulnerable then we experience
the love of god in a deep sense of
connection
to
others
i want to invite
my friend adam thompson
uh on with us adam is a member here at
the table
uh and he's definitely dealt um just
really profoundly with kind of
everything we're discussing uh tonight
and one of the things i so appreciate
about adam is his vulnerability
and honesty and insensitivity he's um
just wonderful and so he's he's taught
me so much about that uh so adam
welcome my friend
um
so
uh so you found you know the table um
pretty early on after our launch uh
about a year ago or so um so could you
kind of start by just describing tell us
a little bit of the story like you know
your life before coming to the table um
and and you know what was your mindset
your emotional state like kind of you
know your headspace like where where
were you
uh
i was before the table i was just
very anxious and
i wanted to be
left alone and not be around people and
i was just one of those people who just
wanted to like keep to myself and just
be
shut in and not like deal with anyone
and
and my anxious brains just
left me so lonely and
no one did feel like i had no one to
turn to really
yeah so it was you were so you were
spending a lot of time
um
in your house
you know alone that was that was a lot
of your kind of life
yeah yeah
yeah um so tell me a little bit about
um so you found the table was it online
did you do like a google search or
something what was the i'm trying to
remember how you found that i did it
okay
he googled
google um
and so you find us and you're like okay
i'm going to
go to a church now you didn't really
have so much of a church background if i
recall that that wasn't something you
really grew up um necessarily going
every sunday or anything so this is a
pretty new experience for you
so you're you're gonna go to this church
like walk me through
that experience where like um yeah just
what was what was that like walking
through those doors for the first time
oh man
part of me was just like yeah you're
going to church for the first time and
the other part was like
what are you doing here why are we here
i was just so nervous and
i was like afraid
someone wouldn't judge me or find out
i'm trans or something and
it just scared me like oh my goodness
i'm here in god's house and
what am i doing here
yeah so there was so you um you named uh
i think about judgment is that was that
the language you just used like kind of
afraid like someone's gonna
judge you so it sounds like there was
just a lot of kind of a lot of fear
um
and because you're going from being
mostly alone to all of a sudden well you
know church at least like not church
online that's a different vibe but you
know they're in person like it's people
and and all that so um and i remember
your your first sunday and um
i was so proud of you because i could
tell you were real scared
but you totally you pushed through man
like you pushed through and you did it
um so
kind of walk me through you know the the
months after that
you know what
what has it meant you know to you to
kind of be a part of this this community
um you know and and you've engaged in
things like even you know a meet up and
such so um you know how how has all that
kind of come together to to help you
um
you know kind of or how has it helped
you i guess i'll ask it like that how
has that helped kind of shift you away
from the place you were into something
um you know kind of better talk me
through that
oh jeez
mean you guys have just changed my life
so much i
i was
even afraid to like got into my life
because
i
just figured you're just so judgmental
of people similar to me and
i know he was just only trying to help
me and
[Music]
lead me toward a better life and
i found it with the table in all of you
and
i'm just honestly so blessed
that you all on the table are in my life
and i couldn't ask for a better life
than this and
it just
warms my heart there are people who are
accepting and
that
i shouldn't be afraid to be who i am
because that's what you all have taught
me
i just want to thank you all
you are
so very welcome my friend
i love what you named about um there at
the end about feeling
that kind of freedom
to to be yourself that like you can be
loved just right right where you're at
um
and that's
that's a huge huge
um
that's a huge insight and not just to
get intellectually you know but to like
get like here you know i mean the heart
like to let that start to sink in
and um
yeah that's that's pretty that's pretty
amazing so man thank you for
um
thank you for being a part of us and
thank you
for stepping out um not only tonight
it's like share a little bit and you
know kind of
open up but really that first time you
know to be brave
to be vulnerable to step out like you
did and push through some of that
intense fear and anxiety and um and then
just to see on the back side you know
what god
not just has done but is continuing to
do in your life in your heart and your
mind it's
it's
stinking amazing
so
we're really we're really proud of you
we've i've had people um
other leaders when we started the table
or people who kind of helped us start it
have have told me like man if we started
this church community just for adam
it would have been worth it
and i think there's a lot of truth in
that um
so we love you lots thank you for for
opening up and
and sharing did you have any um anything
else you wanted to name or encourage
others others with before um you kind of
transition
um just to be yourself and don't let
don't be afraid to let god into your
life because
he won't judge you for who you are he
loves you
unconditionally
it's perfect
well thank you thank you my friend
appreciate you
appreciate you thank you
well
um
i love that guy
that's greatness so
uh just to kind of close this out
tonight i wanted to um
kind of name
uh that
you know
i know there can be
kind of certain um
i don't know how to i quite had to frame
it kind of um stereotypes you know
uh gender
and you know statements like all women
should be x or all men act like y or you
know whatever those kinds of things are
um kind of generally overstatements
um
but there are some statistically kind of
significant um differences in kind of
how males and females you know roughly
tend to be
and um if you in fact if you look kind
of across the world um women tend to
live about six to eight years longer
than men and one of the reasons um
basically seems to be that that females
tend to
basically open up create better
connections have more friends be more
intentional about cultivating
relationships and and just generally
tend to um be more vulnerable and open
and sharing
and so
i wanted to to speak to all the uh the
folks who identify as male who can hear
my voice right now i want to encourage
you um for the sake of your own
spiritual emotional physical health um
just all the reasons for the for the
sake of even your your own um children
if you have them just the example you're
setting for for your family
um
i just want to name we've got some work
to do
and and so i just want to um encourage
yes everyone but especially uh those of
the male persuasion listening to me
right now if you're not currently um if
you don't have community if you don't
have you know a group of people that
you're really opening up to and sharing
some of what's going on not just in your
head but in your heart um i really want
to um just encourage you to join uh one
of our our meetups that's what we call
our small groups um here at the table
it's it's the thing that adam joined one
of those and i know it's been really
huge in his life um
and so yeah i just encourage you to to
get connected
and um
because i really i i want this year you
know we've got a few more months for
sure of of this season we're in
and i don't want anyone
at the table a part of us you know to to
experience a crushing loneliness um in
this season when i get it it's a weird
crazy year and so i just encourage you
find some community um it takes and you
might say well i just want my community
i just want to form naturally and
organically
um awesome so do i but you know what
sometimes you just have to be
intentional i think again of adam um
stepping out and it wasn't necessary it
didn't probably feel natural and organic
for him to you know step out go to
church join a small group and all that
um but he was intentional
and then out of that god has done just
such amazing amazing things and so um i
just encourage us all um as we close out
this year to to move into a more
communal way of being so that the chains
of loneliness
in our life and our community
can be broken
all right let me pray for you lord jesus
i just thank you
for
um every person hearing my voice right
now god you are up to something
beautiful in their lives
and i
um
i pray that you would call them out of
isolation
out of any fakeness
or need to
pretend and perform
and i call them god by your spirit into
their true selves
into vulnerability into honesty god do
that work deep in their hearts and minds
i thank you for them i thank you for
this this church community got all that
you're up to in our lives may you
continue to take us deeper
in the powerful name of jesus i pray
amen
okay
[Music]
you have a place
it feels like you lost yourself again
[Music]
receive your own
is
[Music]
ourselves that is
[Applause]
[Music]
you have a heart
in time
[Music]
with me my friends
my friends
[Music]
it feels like you lost yourself again
sitting in the
when you are fully known
[Applause]
[Music]
it feels like you lost yourself
[Applause]
if
[Music]
[Applause]
you have
you have a problem
[Music]
i love that song and i love those
singers and musicians um i was actually
just looking up the lyrics to the song
if you want to look them up too the song
is titled known and loved and man the
lyrics are powerful
and thank you so much for joining us
tonight
i hope that the service blessed you and
reminded you that you are
not alone
um
and i also want to say a special thank
you to those that have been working
behind the scenes for these services for
the last eight months these things don't
just
create or produce themselves it takes a
lot of work behind the scenes so
thank you to scott and gary and
everybody on our tech team
mindy for always coming up with the most
beautiful worship sets and all of our
musicians who practice throughout the
week
to sound so beautiful
sarah and her team who do such a great
job with hospitality and making sure
everything gets posted in our comments
and people are seen and
personally welcomed in the comments
every week
and also to uh brett um who continuously
reaches out to all of us every week to
make sure that we remember that we are
loved and known and connected and part
of
this community not just in words but in
action um so
uh yeah i mean it
really does take a village for you guys
so thank you all for tuning in and
thanks to everybody for contributing
um
also if you resonate with the vision and
the values and what's shared here uh in
our community would you consider a
financial gift to the table um any
amount would be so appreciated um i
believe giving tuesday's coming up this
week it's a great opportunity to give a
one-time gift or recurring gift um just
to continue to
uh help our community to to flourish and
to do the work we feel called to do and
the work we want to continue doing um
you can do that at our website
www.thetabletx.org
thetabletx.org
and as you go into your week let me send
you out with this benediction and
blessing
you are a child of god
this is true on your best days
and on your worst days
you are wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only one you
nothing about you is a mistake
and this world needs you being fully
yourself authentic and free
so as you go into the week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love
to everyone you come in contact with
have a great week and we'll see you back
here next sunday bye
you